this morning we remember nearly 3 000
lives lost 19 years ago
in the worst terror attack this country
has ever seen in about 30 minutes we
will pause for a moment of silence to
mark the moment
the first plane hit the world trade
center that was 19 years ago and you
will see ceremonies to remember
the attacks in lower manhattan at the
pentagon and at the flight 93 memorial
near shanksville pennsylvania in all
more than 2 700 people were killed at
the world trade center alone
including hundreds of new york city
firefighters and other first responders
right now more than a dozen recent fdny
academy graduates
are children of fallen 9 11 heroes and
they are now weeks away from completing
their
standard probationary period and
becoming full-on firefighters among them
two brothers leonard and anthony regalia
we spoke to them about their decision
to follow in their father's legacy
[Applause]
it was a bright tuesday morning 19 years
ago when terrorists turned commercial
airliners into weapons of mass
destruction
thousands of lives lost gone in an
instant
what came down though what came down the
crash the other trade center's down it's
down
it's down
as people ran away from the danger in
lower manhattan
first responders ran toward it including
about half
of new york city's fire units come down
the steps everything fine till we got to
the basement and everything just fell in
in the final tally 343 firefighters
never returned that morning
including 15 men from engine 54
known as the pride of midtown this is
the actual roll call from 9 11
yep that's the that's the exact roll
call what happened to everyone else on
that
list uh everybody passed away that day
on that one and that one
why leave that up why walk by that every
day
they like they always say you know you
never forget you always
you have that memory of how great those
guys were
every member of the fdny lost a friend
or a colleague that morning
but leonard and anthony regalia just
kids at the time
lost something more what do you remember
that morning
my grandmother picked me up from school
that day
we went home and
you know they eventually had said you
know your dad is missing we're looking
for him
everyone's just sitting around watching
the tv you know waiting by the phone
hoping for the best
leonard regalia senior their father was
just 36 years old
how do you think he would have felt
seeing you guys wear these uniforms
i think he would have felt very proud of
it extremely proud yes
he had passed away you know doing what
he loved to do help people
and that's the reason why i chose this
job and uh
you know i'm i have the honor and
privilege of working in the same
firehouse that he worked in the same
company
so really means a lot to me i always had
admiration always looked up to my dad
and what he did
and then i think as i matured and as the
time went on
year after year it became more and more
of something i wanted to do
leonard junior remembers visiting his
dad at the firehouse
the very same one where he now works has
it changed much since when you were a
kid
well looks to say i even have the honor
of working with a few guys that work
with my dad
they still work in this firehouse today
really what do they say about him
oh great funny stories they said you
know he was the biggest guy in the house
that when he would go work out in the
gym the next guy's workout would be
taking all his weights off
i could see you inherited some of that a
little a little bit
so uh you know even if we're cooking a
meal in the kitchen they'd be like oh
your father would have put
two sticks of butter not just one
he's you know gets to see firsthand what
it was like
through the guys to work with my dad but
um
[Music]
just you know even though i'm in a
different borough different house and
stuff like that
just knowing that i do what he did it
really brings me a long way and helps me
every day to do what i love to do
after the academy anthony joined engine
217 in brooklyn
we keep hearing calls coming in just as
we're sitting here right now
i think those are calls right yes you
ever think that
the next call could be a call like the
one your father went to
you always have the chance of that
happening but just as he did i'd be
ready to go
and i'd feel honored doing it knowing
that that was he
that was what he was doing that day so
i'd feel honored
it was a tragedy for your family and it
has so much meaning
for your households how do you hope
america remembers
9 11 i just hope that
any of the memorials or uh stuff that
they do every year never goes away you
know it's
it's something that can't be pushed to
the side everybody needs to know what
happened that day
the tragedy and uh the guys that gave
their lives
need to be remembered why is it
important to remember
i think you know they always say we will
never forget
and it should be something that is
instilled years and years later
no matter how much time passes because i
think the event itself shows you the
danger
of what they really go through every day
and what can happen on any day
that's an amazing thing talking to those
guys and to see what is in that
firehouse there in midtown
uh the the call sheet on the whiteboard
from the day of
that game 18 years ago they see their
dads their dad's name is there and
people have written notes over the years
we love you we miss you that kind of
thing
uh he was noz is next to his name that
means he was on the nozzle so he would
have been at the end of the hose yeah
and and there's there's signage like
that in every firehouse in new york city
is because as you point out 343
firefighters lost their
lives that day but you know when we keep
looking at the video of 9 11 as we
always do on these days it's still so
hard to believe
that the the the day was so beautiful
and the sky was so clear
it was it's incomprehensible that that
could happen in the united states
when every time those pictures play i
still get a visceral reaction in my gut
i am like
upset immediately yes yes it does turn
all that up but i was so touched
by the brothers that at least they could
laugh that they could hear good memories
about their dad
i know that picture tony that you showed
at the dad and they're both kissing him
on either
yes that's the thing that just melts
your heart that they will always have
that
it's so great they're carrying on their
father and there are about 10 other
young firefighters also carrying on a
family tradition and i think as we
approach the 20th anniversary next year
you're going to see even more
of that because all of these five six
seven eight-year-olds who were kids on 9
11
they're now becoming adults and and
making their own mark on the world
and i think the brothers make a good
point where they say we hope no one ever
forgets we will never forget i think
that's
that's why it's so important to have
that ceremony that we have every year
even though it's different this year
because of covid
i don't think that that would ever ever
ever stop it's so important to do
no we won't we won't that's right bravo
to the brothers they're both great
yeah i like them a lot yeah that's great
when did you do that when did you
yesterday after yesterday wow
that's a fast one yeah all right